what is a popular film whose script
breaks all of the screenwriting rules
and yet it's still success and how often
does this happen and this is something
that bothers you in any way an
interesting question and to answer you
really have to go to that concept of
screenwriting rules and when I in my
anatomy of story class I talked about
all of the fundamental key elements that
have to be in your script for it to be a
great story and that's what we're really
talking about how do you tell a great
story in that sense there is no popular
film that I can tell you that breaks
those rules because we're talking about
two different concepts of what rule
means most people when they think about
the rules of writing are they're really
talking about these very simple
conventional type of ideas about what
makes a good script which I'm not
interested in because to me that is
mechanical writing that's that's
paint-by-numbers script writing and that
simply won't work when I talk about the
rules of good story I'm talking about
these key comments way under the surface
that link a story together so that it
built steadily from beginning to end now
at that level of story what I call the
grammar of drama the way a story can
build so that it has the greatest impact
on the audience there is no way to write
a great script that doesn't hit those
beats now here's here's the qualifier
which is that when you transcend ajaan
when you use for example advanced
storytelling techniques you come up with
a story that appears to break those
basic rules but it doesn't what it's
doing is simply coming up with
characters and story structures
that are more complex they're not the
simple chronological beginning to the
end type of story and they might be have
these stories might have a main
character who is quote unlikable that's
one of those conventional rules that I
mentioned that you hear when you're
first starting out as a writer and
saying oh I have to have a likeable hero
well not so that that is as false and so
it's in very important for writers to
understand what these quote rules are
that actually make for a great story and
these so-called conventional rules that
are not true that is certainly not true
now and they probably never were
you